a plagiarism story has an unexpected
plot twist clip can be used for video
surveillance and schmidt hooper goes on
another rant on his blog about citing
his works welcome to ml news
hello friends of the monday it is ml
news and our first story is convoluted
uh no pun intended so it starts out with
a reddit post by user chong 98 alleging
plagiarism
of a paper they refer to a story of
plagiarism that we at ml news here have
covered about momentum residual neural
networks they say today i found out that
our paper still in conference review is
also severely plagiarized by this other
paper so they made a little github
readme documenting that they have
uploaded their paper to archive first
and detailed comparison of what they
accused the other paper of plagiarizing
largely it comes down to the idea is
very similar and it's applied on
different data sets but essentially the
same method also some formulations are
quite similar and their conclusion reads
usually the methods that work extremely
well in practice are very simple and we
are happy to find that lad which is
their method is one of these techniques
we encourage people to try out our
proposed led to improve our results for
object detection give us appropriate
credit however we are extremely upset if
our idea is obviously stolen saying that
the other authors must withdraw their
paper now we know that plagiarism like
this happens quite a bit in machine
learning there are just so many papers
and it's very difficult to even detect
if another paper has plagiarized your
paper it's difficult for reviewers to
find out that the paper is a copy of
some other work a lot of people are
hoping to get publications and by simply
taking paper rewriting them a little bit
maybe doing one or two different
experiments and then submitting them
somewhere else however there is a twist
user zill 24 says something very
interesting is going on here because
just a couple of days ago this exact
paper has been found to plagiarize word
by word another paper by chinese authors
submitted in 2020 and has thus caused
many discussions on chinese forums and
this links to chihu which is sort of a
chinese quora and they put their paper
and this paper side by side and it turns
out not to be an approximate plagiarism
but actually copy the paper in part word
by word or at least phrase by phrase so
this is a near-duplicate paper right
here of this paper if you're confused so
was i
and apparently so is the original poster
of the plagiarism claim saying i'm never
aware of the paper you mentioned but for
sure i'll read and cite it if it's the
same idea thanks for pointing out and as
you can see people are generally lost so
here's what happened so the paper we
considered first let's call that paper a
that paper has been written and
submitted to a conference and uploaded
on archive this year in august the paper
they claim plagiarized them was uploaded
to archive in september as you can see
by the date let's call this paper b the
reddit post claims paper b having very
similar ideas copied from paper a
however then an author of yet another
paper paper c comes along and shows
pretty convincingly that paper b is
actually a copy of paper c including
screenshots of the diagrams and so on
paper c also delivers proof of first
submission and so on and you can even
analyze that paper b did in fact
screenshot paper c because the
resolution of their figures is worse
here is the interesting part not only
was paper c written a year before but
also it was never released publicly it
was submitted to two conferences and
then after rejection the author simply
dropped it because they thought their
idea wasn't that good so paper c was
before paper a and paper b but was never
released so there are multiple questions
now like how did paper b's authors get
access to paper c now this post on chuho
tries to follow that up so they're
trying to contact the university they're
trying to find these people they find
that the main authors no longer study
there one of the authors apparently says
well i just kind of uploaded it to
archive but i didn't really write the
paper nobody admits to anything nobody
says anything the nurif's chairs checked
and it turns out none of the area chairs
senior area chairs or reviewers is at
the institution that plagiarized the
paper so as of yet it is still unclear
who leaked the paper and how where these
authors got it from nor does anyone in
this chain admit to any plagiarism now
while this obviously sucks for the
researchers of paper c the question is
what about paper a now so paper a made
the claim that since paper b's claims
were so similar and paper b was after
paper a paper b copied from paper a but
now you have a paper that's essentially
a copy from paper b yeah it was before
paper a so when the same logic indicate
that paper a copied from paper c the
authors of paper a actually comment on
this and say they did not know about
paper c when they wrote their paper they
now highlight the differences between
the two papers they strongly deny having
plagiarized paper c and the whole thing
is just a mess
now is there something to learn from
this i i think yes and i think that's
what makes it so hard in these
plagiarism cases i don't know anything
more than you do but if i had to guess i
believe the authors of paper a here that
they didn't know about paper c but it
just shows you how multiple people and
they self-admit the idea is relatively
simple and and works how multiple people
can have very similar ideas and then
write papers that essentially turn out
to be very similar to each other and
among the thousands of papers that are
released each month it's bound to happen
that some of them with the same idea
doing the same sorts of applications
will turn out to be quite overlapping
without ever having seen each other and
that might be indistinguishable from a
paper that has actually plagiarized
another paper but has done so putting in
a little bit of work to reformulate and
redo experiments so while plagiarism is
certainly a problem in our field and
it's probably happening a lot more than
we realize in this smarter way that is
undetected it is also the case that you
have to be quite careful with these
allegations and in general probably the
best thing you can do is simply to
publish your ideas write them up as well
as possible and just make it easy and
and nice for people to cite you instead
of citing someone who copies from you
and yes that means that there is a
little bit of a marketing aspect
involved in this and it also leads to
problems where people with bigger
followings will attract more citations
but ultimately it is your best shot with
regard to this particular story i doubt
that anything more is going to happen
here we'll keep an eye on it
next news github user joan moden
demonstrates how you can use clip so
open ai's clip model to search through
videos apparently in the original clip
paper openai claimed that this is not
really an application that this doesn't
really work well however as this little
project demonstrates it appears to work
quite well in the way that you can
search surveillance footage for a
descriptive sort of text so what you do
is you take your video you encode each
frame with clip and then you encode the
text that you're looking for also with
clip and then you compute the inner
products between all the frames and what
you're looking for and if any of the
frames exceed a threshold then you will
show that frame so here the author
searches for the text a truck with the
text or voila and directly finds the
frame corresponding to that a white bmw
car a truck with the text jcn a
bicyclist with a blue shirt a blue smart
car and it's pretty easy to also do this
yourself you clone the repo you put in
your own video you can search through it
now this raises a lot of questions this
gives essentially a new super power to
people who have access to this kind of
material tracking was possible before
but not with this ease you'd have to
craft some sort of a detector in order
to label a bunch of things in some of
the images and then you might be able to
track it through the footage but here
you can simply enter what you're looking
for in many different ways now you can
of course ask what's the purpose of
having surveillance apparatus in the
first place if it's not for you know
surveilling so rather than criticizing
the possibilities here one might
criticize the implementation of
surveillance in the first place but and
it's also the case that you might simply
have these surveillance cameras for the
purpose of proving someone like running
a red light or something like this but
once it's in place it can obviously be
misused for other things and with the
addition of clip now that's an easier
possibility i don't know i don't have
the answer here i'd just like people to
know that things like this are now
totally possible not only to the
government but pretty much anyone who
has access to this camera feed and a
home computer so make of that as you
will
next news the darpa subterranean
challenge has concluded now this is
something extremely cool the task here
is that submissions to the challenge are
teams of humans and robots that explore
underground areas so this can be mine
shafts or underground tunnels or
anything like this so this is a
competition and the way it works is that
the robot or robots and usually there's
multiple robots are deployed into this
underground system and are tasked with
doing certain tasks like finding things
retrieving things mapping the area while
the humans aren't allowed to go into the
underground areas they can communicate
with the robots however this being mine
shafts and so on there isn't always
reliable communication so the robots
must largely be autonomous and this
isn't only simulated this is actually
real world robots for example here is a
drone in one of these underground
bunkers being hit by a plastic bag that
it itself has thrown up with the wind so
evan ackermann on twitter has a number
of really cool clips from this challenge
so the challenge has concluded you can
no longer participate this year but you
can look at the participants at the
trials on youtube this is just really
cool
jurgen schmidt uber pumps out another
blog post claiming to correct mistakes
in citations in historical references by
others this time he criticizes the 2021
turing lecture by joshua benjo yanuka
and jeff hinton which they gave after
receiving the touring award it also
criticizes the announcement of the
touring award all of them for as i said
making wrong historical claims and not
properly citing things smith uber
himself starts out the blog post by
saying we must stop crediting the wrong
people for inventions made by others and
in the abstract he states most of these
breakthroughs and tools however were
direct consequences of the breakthroughs
of my lab and other labs in the past
three decades and he makes 15 distinct
claims about the touring lecture such as
lbh which stands for la benjo hinton
cite hinton for dropout without
mentioning that dropout is just a
variant of hansen's 1990 stochastic
delta rule or such as lbh cite benjal's
2014 paper on generative adversarial
networks without mentioning that gans
are instances of the adversarial
curiosity principle of 1990. and he
follows this up with detailed references
to his claims as well as over 250
references
a lot of which are to himself i have
sided with schmidt huber a lot of times
in the past it is true that his labs
have done a lot of fundamental work it
is also true that sometimes this work is
not properly credited and i can even
understand that he's pretty salty about
laka banjo and hinton receiving the
touring award and him not but this is
pushing it a little bit like just the
sheer length of this article he sees
himself as something like a crusader for
the correction of scientific history for
making sure everyone sides properly and
so on and i agree that is an important
thing but i asked myself is this really
what he wants to be remembered for does
he want his legacy to be oh schmidt
hoover the person who did a lot of cool
work okay we might not credit him for
all the cool work he did but still
people remember him for a lot of cool
work or does he want to be remembered as
the person where every single time
someone invents anything he finds a
vague relation to what he did in the
1990s and then claims oh this is just a
special version of my case and look at
the length of this article the amount of
work going into this is just absurd like
he's so smart clearly he could do
something better with his time and this
isn't even productive at the frequency
and intensity that schmidt hoover is
doing this this is completely
counterproductive no one is even going
to respond to this people will simply
say ah ah here he goes again and ignore
him and the claims get more and more
wild while you can make the claim that
something like a resnet is essentially a
highway net but simpler the claims that
gans are just a special case of
artificial curiosity it might be true in
an abstract level but certainly not on a
practical level and then his newest
claims that transformers are essentially
nothing else than fast weight
programmers and so on i mean
come on if this are actually all special
cases of your things then please please
tell us what the next big thing is
transformers have not only sparked a
revolution in nlp they have widespread
consequences people worry about do
language models really understand people
can solve new tasks with them google
search is now powered by bert and
schmidt uber claims to just have been
sitting on this for 20 years well please
next time tell us beforehand so we can
rein in the revolution faster in any
case read this if you want i don't think
it's worth your time
openai has a new blog post called
summarizing books with human feedback
and a paper to go along with it called
recursively summarizing books with human
feedback i don't know why they've left
out the recursive from the blog post but
in any case so the algorithm works by
taking a book chunking it up into
sections and then summarizing each of
the sections and then putting together
the summaries of those sections and then
summarizing those into super sections
and so on every summary generation is
conditioned on the section it's supposed
to summarize but also at the summaries
that have been produced from sections
that come before it at the same level
this is something you can see here at
the height one so generation of this
super summary here would not only
receive the things it's supposed to
summarize but also the summaries that
have been generated before it so
essentially you're telling the model
here's a bunch of text i want you to
summarize it's from the middle of a
story and here is a high level summary
of what already happened in this story
please continue this high level summary
so this is cool because doing this at
this chunking level and not as a please
summarize the whole book task you get
more accurate you can leverage humans in
a better way because humans can now
simply check whether a reasonable length
text like a couple of pages have been
summarized correctly and not whether an
entire book has been summarized
correctly and also this allows you to
summarize arbitrarily long text because
you can just always add levels and
therefore if your original text is
longer you simply recursively summarize
it more often because with each
recursion the text gets chunked then
each chunk gets summarized and then all
of this goes together so this is a neat
combination of the principles of
learning from human feedback which is a
thing that openai has shown interest
before and also recursive task
decomposition where you can divide a
task into essentially the same task at
lower levels therefore you can learn one
model to do the task and then simply
apply that model over and over again the
model they end up using is a fine-tuned
version of gpt-3 and you can read some
of the example summaries on the blog
post for example this one from alice in
wonderland now i've read the summaries
and i have to say they're not exactly
what you would expect from a summary of
a book in that they seem to pick out
important events that happen in the book
but the highest level summaries they
don't really give you like a sensible
overview over the plot of a book and
this might be due to this recursive
decomposition so while it might be
appropriate at the lowest level to
simply sort of leave away all the
in-between whatever the author sprinkled
in and simply mention the important
events of a chapter if you go higher
level you most often want sort of a more
abstract summary you want to condense
the plot somehow so there's still room
for improvement here but it's pretty
cool to see what these language models
can do when you bring the human into the
loop
cnn business writes a startup says its
software can spot racial bias within
companies will this surveillance scare
employees now this is a product called
unbias it eliminating buys with
technology one alert at a time so what
this product does is it monitors the
employees of a company for example their
email communication and it tries to
detect instances of bias so the cnn
articles mentions this example for
instance she said if an email from one
employee to another alluded to a
diversity hire that's the kind of thing
the software would be expected to flag
so the way it works is here if unbiased
it scans an email and finds wording that
may be objectionable it will send an
alert to a small group of employees
working in human resources and diversity
equity and inclusion with the wording in
question highlighted in yellow the
spokesperson says it's not looked at as
a gotcha for employees because the bias
might be unconscious so the consequences
might be that you offer an employee bias
related training or other education the
interesting thing is that it says it
doesn't use artificial intelligence to
determine when to send an alert because
of concerns surrounding the possibility
that bias could be contained in ai
itself and that it essentially relies on
keyword and phrase spotting the product
website makes a big deal that the
companies applying the product are in
control they can define what the
criteria are and so on and they frame it
more as a compliance issue comparing it
to similar tools which detect instances
of for example insider trading however
if this doesn't scare the crap out of
you then i honestly don't know and it's
only a matter of time before machine
learning is actually used in these
systems because as they are they seem to
be pretty easy to evade and when the
company wants to improve their detection
and they'll implement some sort of an
nlp system that's certainly going to
make things more interesting but not
necessarily more pleasant and i highly
doubt this is going to change anyone's
mind or unconscious biases or increase
in substantial ways the workspace
climates
[Music]
speaking of surveillance apple is
working on iphone features to help
detect depression cognitive decline the
wall street journal writes so this story
is about apple monitoring users in order
to detect things like depression and
mild cognitive impairment which is a
precursor for example to alzheimer's or
other forms of dementia now for this i'm
honestly not that skeptical given that i
hope you will have the ability to turn
it off but if this is an optional
feature it could potentially be quite
helpful people generally let their smart
watches and their phones track other
health related data such as pulse oxygen
saturation number of steps heart rate
heart rate variability well heart rate
is the same as pulse right doesn't
matter so while i certainly agree that
mental health data isn't exactly the
same it probably requires monitoring
more personal data than simply a number
which is your pulse we do face a lack of
mental health professionals and having
the system monitor you for something
like cognitive decline might be helpful
in that you might be encouraged to go
look for treatment a lot sooner than you
would if you simply had to notice it
yourself because if something declines
mildly over time you're unlikely to see
it yourself but of course the privacy
implications for something like this
especially if this data is then sent
around and analyzed and potentially even
sold are pretty great so treat this with
a grain of salt
next news cnbc writes the uk publishes a
10-year plan to become an ai superpower
seeking to rival the us and china so
this article details the uk strategy to
become a leader internationally in ai
technology it's something like a 10-year
plan and it outlines a strategy and this
strategy goes from providing more
compute to launching centers where
researchers from the whole country can
communicate with each other and
coordinate ai research it also outlines
some better regulations for intellectual
property and so on and it appears to be
just a general indicator that the
government is looking to push this area
however there are multiple problems with
something like this first of all
academics are very likely to move not
only academics also employees of tech
companies they're pretty move happy a
lot of them are not bound to individual
location and it is even considered a
good career move for example in academia
if you have spent time at various
different places so as a country
retaining knowledge is quite a hard task
if it comes to people like this it is a
bit easier with industry where a company
actually needs headquarters and so on
but also there employees frequently
rotate the other problematic aspect is
actually also outlined in this article
and that is that ai startups like many
startups get bought and very often they
get actually bought by us or chinese big
corporations so in this case britain
might have raised these startups given
them tax breaks or subsidies or grants
and whatnot built up all this knowledge
in the country only then for it to be
bought by a u.s firm the article for
example names deepmind as such an
example now while deepmind is still in
london it now belongs to google it's
good to see that countries are pushing
ai technology but it does detail the
problem you have when trying to achieve
something like this especially as a
country that is not huge such as the uk
okay let's dive into some helpful
libraries scikit-learn learn is
i'm kidding you know psychic learn but
scikit-learn has just released the 1.0
release for some projects 1.0 release is
sort of the initial release first stable
version and so on for other libraries
the 1.0 release is actually the last
release saying okay we're done with this
we're releasing 1.0 that's it
scikit-learn doesn't appear that either
of these are true of course scikit-learn
is already an established library but it
doesn't seem like they have any
intention of finishing or killing the
project there are also no major changes
in the library one of the changes is
that lots of functions now have to be
called with keyword arguments which
let's face it in numpy and scikit-learn
and all of these functions is a good
change now while i think it would be
better to simply educate the users to do
this as a good practice and leave them
the option of filling their code with
non-keyword arguments nah it's their
library they can do whatever they want
they're also a bunch of new models and
the plotting library has been also
improved also new release dopamine
version 4 is out so dopamine is a
library for doing reinforcement learning
research with lots of implementations of
common agents and environments and the
major new additions are things like soft
actor critic for continuous control and
the op tax optimization library for jax
based agents also new is that it's now
compatible with docker so it will become
a lot easier to set up the required
environments in the future microsoft
releases music which isn't necessarily a
library it's simply an umbrella project
for music generation research so this
repo holds code for a bunch of different
papers in various aspects of synthetic
music generation and also artificial
understanding of music that already
exists this can go from classification
of genre to transcription of lyrics all
the way to arranging and synthesizing
new music including lyrics now what's
cool about music is that not only does
it have this picture logo but they
actually do have their logo in midi and
you can listen to their logo
[Music]
excellent facebook air releases dina
task a new paradigm of ai benchmarking
and this is an iteration on dyna bench
so this is a system for benchmarking ai
systems specifically natural language
processing tasks so this is supposed to
combine tasks which are essentially data
set and their associated labels and on
the other hand models that people submit
and it evaluates the models on the task
but also there's the option to have the
human in the loop something like a
mechanical turk worker that goes and
tries to come up with some sort of
adversarial examples against the models
or examples about a particular aspect of
the task the human created data is then
fed back into the system and used as
further evaluation data so this is
supposed to give a more complete picture
of model's capabilities rather than
simply evaluating them over and over on
the same limited set of static
benchmarks so if you're interested in
that sort of thing this seems like a
pretty good framework to go about it
next up phi flow has a new release out
and this is a framework for solving
partial differential equations in a
differentiable manner so as you can see
right here this can be for example used
for fluid dynamics now i'm a total noob
at any of these things but if you're in
these fields this library might be
interesting for you the next library is
dora the explorer a friendly experiment
manager by facebook research and this is
an experiment manager that focuses on
specifically things like grid searches
and the special thing here is that the
experiments themselves are defined in
pure python files so there's no yaml
there's no web interface or anything
like this your experiments are simply
python files defining some sort of a
grid search and the tool can identify
and deduplicate experiments that happen
from i guess gridding too much so it
seems to be a simpler alternative to
many of the experiment running tools out
there if for some reason you're looking
for simplicity you might want to give
this a try now being said that it seems
simple the system actually looks really
powerful too so i have no doubt that you
can go up in complexity with this by a
lot for example it does interface with
scheduling systems such as slurm
next up habitat lab is a high-level
library for development in embodied ai
this is essentially a library that helps
you run rl and robotics tasks in 3d
environments this is not a new library
but there have been some new
developments first of all there is a new
data set called habitat matterport 3d
dataset that brings real world
environment into the habitat environment
so these are real rooms that were
scanned by a depth sensor by a
depth-aware camera and now you can
explore these real environments inside
the habitat framework so if you are into
embodied ai robotics indoor navigation
anything like this definitely give
habitat a try go to toilet
good job and lastly google ai announces
wit a wikipedia-based image text data
set this is supposed to be a very high
quality data set connecting images to
text so rather than scraping the
internet and trying to read the alt text
from an image this leverages wikipedia
so on wikipedia whenever there's an
image there's actually a lot of
information about that image all around
it not only is there the usual
description but there's also the page
title that usually refers to something
inside the image and the data set also
grabs the page description which very
often also relates to an image on the
page and lastly the image page itself
also usually has something like an
attribution description and the file
name can also give indications about
what is in the image the cool thing
about this is since wikipedia is so
extensive that you not only get image
text pairs but you very often get a lot
of translations for all of these
different things into different
languages so this is an example of one
data point that you would get you get
the image along with url page title
reference description attribution
description and so on oh i said
attribute description before attribution
description sorry ah so while this is a
smaller data set than what for example
dali was trained on it's definitely a
higher quality data set with lots of
more information per day to point it's
going to be pretty exciting to see what
people build from it alright this was
already it for ml news this was a long
episode i realized this but there's just
so much stuff happening if you have
anything happening let me know and i'll
see you next time bye bye
[Music]